you know bob was supposed to be banned
from the show i think the ban is over
but yeah i wondered what was going on
with bobo bobo hasn't been able to get
past ralph
to get a question or a phone call in
this whole time so bobo was frustrated
and he left us a message
about will smith at the oscars the
academy is shameful should have had a
security team in place especially in
these times anything can happen
will smith should have his award taken
away case closed by the way it's the
academy not the academy it's the academy
academy
it's the academy it's shameful
should have had a security team in place
especially in these hard times anything
can happen will smith should have his
award taken away case closed you know
it's weird because we banned bobo i
would not be able to tell you why we
banned bobo
remember
i think because i wanted to be taken out
of the wack pack
i'm not on the backpack yeah right right
right marianne from brooklyn is anybody
even missing bobo he ta he texts me
every morning to see if uh he's gonna
get on but his punishment was three
months his punishment isn't over until
the end of april uh ralph is in charge
of bobo's punishment do you have an
update
yeah well if you'll remember it was like
a three-pronged punishment and the first
thing was if he doesn't do what he's
supposed to it's gonna be six months it
was three months minimum six months
maximum and the first thing he was
supposed to do is change his name from
bobo to
stephen from florida and he didn't do
that so it's six months our own john
blitz says ralph dropped the ball with
bobo let me hear this really he was so
difficult to work with every phone call
turned into half an hour of
the problem with his premise you know he
would always just make an excuse and
another excuse and another excuse to
actually do this you know there needed
to be a little wiggle email i even made
an email so bobo could email me
questions but he didn't do the first
thing so i don't know what to tell you
john how am i you were supposed to email
him john you're saying that ralph is not
performing his duties he passes the buck
he's like you email bobo you do this you
do that i was like ralph this is your
job you came up with the idea it's on
you you can't put your work on me i have
enough to do as it is then he'd say to
you john
you contact bobo i'm too busy i can't
contact bob and then he would say you'd
be like i don't know if this idea is any
good is this idea good i don't know i'm
not sure if we should do this idea even
is it funny what's funny about it you
know is is it funny that boba's
questions are bad but it's just you know
it's a vortex of uh well john i gotta
say something uh
this is not the ralph i know i can't
imagine ralph
no
passing off his work to somebody else
how's that howard john's supposed to
monitor bobo that's his
you're lazy and high all the time ralph
loves to start projects and never finish
them he's an idea man i know that about
rob i never bad idea man useless idea
man
ralphie you were the one who said you
wanted to monitor bobo and deal with it
oh i didn't i didn't she did you said
you were gonna read his questions and if
they weren't any good you were gonna
tell him he can't come on the air
exactly but he didn't do the first part
he didn't change his name ralph didn't
do the first part ralph didn't reach out
to bobo ralph didn't you know rob
listen idiot listen to it i said i'm not
giving bobo any information on me i made
up an email i told you to email him and
tell him this is how he gets in touch
with me this isn't a punishment for me
it's a punishment but i don't have to be
involved with him every two minutes
marianne we need a police officer to
monitor bobo marion from brooklyn
reporting for duty howard i will take
the job over i'll think of a different
punishment we gotta get him back
sometime at the end of april because we
did say three months i'll sleep on it
and i will report thank you tomorrow
there is probation officer marianne from
brooklyn let her deal with bobo